let's talk about bitcoin let's talk
rocket ships
can anything slow down the surge we have
seen in bitcoin
it's the most popular digital currency
on the planet
bitcoin's made some people real rich
real fast
and some major companies are buying in
the world's richest man
now investing 1.5 billion dollars what's
happening with bitcoin
is that people are increasingly learning
that it can be trusted
but plenty of big names won't go near it
bitcoin has no unique value at all it's
a delusion basically
so can bitcoin be trusted how does it
work
and what's bitcoin really worth
there are thousands of cryptocurrencies
out there but the one most people are
talking about
is bitcoin it's a digital currency but
instead of dollars and cents
it's bitcoins and satoshi's and one
bitcoin is worth
100 million satoshi's but unlike the
dollar euro
or yen this currency isn't controlled by
a government
that's what makes bitcoin revolutionary
and to some people
a bit scary
it used to be simple countries would peg
their currencies to the gold stashed in
their central bank
but currencies are now just paper metal
or a number in your bank account and its
value is guaranteed by a government
it's why we trust it we also trust the
banking system
to move our money especially online so
when person a
sends a hundred dollars to person b the
banks make sure that amount is
subtracted from one account and added to
the other
and banks update their ledgers to make
sure people aren't spending money they
no longer have
and of course banks charge fees for all
that work to verify transactions
so what if there was a way to cut out
the banks well that was the original
thinking
behind bitcoin the idea was posted
online in 2008
describing a peer-to-peer version of
electronic cash that you can send from
one party to another
without going through a financial
institution its creator
or creators use the name satoshi
nakamoto
nobody actually to this day is able to
say
who this creator was what we do know
is that the bitcoin white paper was
published
about one month after the big uh crash
of the 2008 financial system it was an
historic day with wall street
shaken to its very foundation today the
losses
staggering the fear climbing it was a
wake-up call
exposing risky banking practices many
people lost
everything including their faith in the
financial system
coincidence or not bitcoin turned up at
the same time
and 10 years later it's still going so
bitcoin is not controlled by a
government
it's not a bank or a company instead
it's
open source software that runs itself or
more accurately
is run by lots of people here's how so
first up
it's called a cryptocurrency because
bitcoin uses encryption to keep it
secure
and instead of bank accounts people
trading bitcoin have two keys
one's private and one is public they're
not actual keys but bits of encrypted
code that fit together
if person a needs to get bitcoin to
person b
they send it to b's public key think of
it like the number on an atm
card person a uses their private key to
encrypt the transaction
and person b uses their private key to
decrypt it
and get their bitcoin those private keys
are like the pin
to the atm card now instead of a bank
verifying that transaction
it's done by a huge network of computers
around the world
and they all have identical copies of
bitcoin's ledger
it's a record of every transaction ever
made that's constantly being updated
so if there's any kind of fraud the
whole network knows about it
that decentralized ledger is called
blockchain
bitcoin transactions are bundled into
blocks and linked together
and each block contains a bit of code
from the previous one
creating a chronology that's supposed to
be impossible to mess with
all the participants in the bitcoin
network are agreeing
that these transactions are what they
are and there's
group witnessing of the transactions so
who are these witnesses
well they're actual people called miners
with powerful computers
this is my mining farm at my apartment
down here is a 6 gpu rx 570 mining rig
miners used to do it all on their own
some still do
but bitcoin's grown and now it takes so
much more computing power
and much more energy so miners often
bound together in what are called pools
some of them build huge warehouses of
servers called farms
the big ones are in china russia but
also places like iceland
where it's just easier to cool those
servers there's a lot of maintenance
involved there's a lot of technical
know-how involved
there's also a lot of energy involved a
cambridge university study says the
entire global bitcoin network
uses more electricity than argentina i
think that people have this idea that
it's like
gold mining but in essence it's a lot
more like just running
like the visa network it's just running
computers
that help people transact but what's in
it for all those miners
well remember bitcoin isn't a company so
miners don't get a salary for adding to
the blockchain
instead the system rewards them in
bitcoin
so transactions are actually floating
around on the bitcoin network
like in a waiting room ready to be
verified miners look for new
transactions
to bundle them in blocks but before they
can add a block
to the chain there's an extra security
check that's pretty unconventional
mining computers have to compete to
solve a coding puzzle
if a miner solves that puzzle first the
block and all the transactions inside it
are added to the blockchain
and that miner is rewarded with some
bitcoin
literally any way you slice it
is profitable another appeal among
crypto fans is this idea that bitcoin is
seen as a hedge against
inflation other currencies suffer when
for example
more money is printed diluting the pool
and weakening its value
bitcoin gets around the inflation
problem by capping its supply at 21
million bitcoins
at the moment roughly 17 million
bitcoins are already in circulation
but there are a few million missing
because some people have lost their
private keys
so how does all the remaining bitcoin
keep its value
well the system slows that supply down
one way
is by cutting the mining rewards in half
every four years
in 2009 the reward was 50 bitcoins for
every block of transactions
added to the blockchain four years later
it was 25
and so on in other words its basic
supply and demand
bitcoin's supply is capped while demand
grows
for now at least so more people are
coming around to the idea that bitcoin
could rival gold eventually but so far
bitcoin's value against other currencies
has been far
from stable it's gone up and down like
crazy
a bitcoin plunging nearly 14 bitcoin is
back up about 10
after a volatile weekend the volatility
is reflective
of lots of speculative investment so i
think that speculative investment is
sort of thinking about bitcoin as
sort of a get rich quick scheme
one of the big runs was when paypal said
it would allow users to buy
hold and sell bitcoin others followed
suit including tesla owned by elon musk
which said it would start accepting
bitcoin as payment too
it has not become mainstream but it is
in the process of becoming mainstream
but is it not everyone gets it or
believes in it
yes companies like microsoft paypal and
mastercard accept bitcoin
you can use bitcoin to buy gift cards at
nike or starbucks
but its use is limited and while crypto
enthusiasts think bitcoin's value is
going to climb even higher
maybe even to the point where one
bitcoin is worth a few hundred thousand
dollars
others say it's just a bubble the only
thing is a speculative
self-fulfilling kind of rise and that
rise is driven
totally by manipulation there are other
concerns with bitcoin too
if something goes wrong you forget or
lose your private key for example
there's no customer service to call
another issue is bitcoin being misused
criminals like it because it's anonymous
the 30 year old is accused of running a
money laundering syndicate
converting almost five and a half
million dollars of cash
into bitcoin so regulators are already
looking into it
cryptocurrencies are a particular
concern we really need to examine ways
in which we can curtail their use and
make sure that
anti-money laundering doesn't occur
through those channels
in the grand scheme of things bitcoin is
still a pretty new concept
some people are willing to take a big
financial risk to chase a potential
fortune
others think there's no way a piece of
code is worth tens of thousands of
dollars
it boils down to trust like any currency
for bitcoin to work enough people have
to buy into it
there's obviously a lot more to bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies
plenty of stuff that we didn't have time
to get into let us know if you'd like
another episode on it
i'll see you next week
you